you're doing the carnivore diet and you  just will you only eat lamb yeah the  carnivore diet which is all animal  products and that's the one that you see  in the news like eggs milk anything that  comes from an animal carnivore diet i  reframed mine as the lion diet  which is insane but i did that i did  that uh and that's  beef lamb or any type of room in an  animal so animals that have multiple  stomachs so you'll eat like beef and  beef and lamb  yeah elk sometimes  nothing else  and salt and water and i reintroduced  tea recently  but you do alcohol  yeah and that just discredits my entire  diet they're like okay you're only  eating oh yeah sure so you have an  autoimmune disorder but you can you can  drink alcohol i think but uh it's  distilled so like vodka and bourbon  there's nothing in it it's distilled  like three times it removes all the  grain so i don't have any autoimmune  problems from alcohol